il y avait un moment qu'on ne l'avait
pas vu à la télévision merci de recevoir
un ancien acteur c'est un septembre
câlin de Louis est apparu la dernière
fois sur le petit écran lors d'un
entretien filmé entre lui le président
ukrainien vaut le dimanche zellenski
rien du tout il y a 87 ans et après deux
AVC Alain Delon encore garder la forme
le célèbre acteur aurait déjà préparé
minutieusement sa succession c'est ma
fille qui sera l'exécutrice
testamentaire elle le sait même si elle
n'aime pas trop qu'on en parle ce sera
elle et personne d'autre sa fille c'est
Anouchka Delon celle qui aura la lourde
tâche d'honorer les dernières volontés
de son père après sa mort et s'il a
choisi ce n'est pas par hasard elle a ma
confiance mon amour mais elle sait ce
qu'elle veut et ce qu'elle fait je ne
voudrais pas que mes enfants se
déchirent comme les Hallyday car on sait
comme chez les Hallyday chez les Delon
tous les enfants ne sont pas logés à la
même enseigne très fusionnel donc
on est tactile a toujours été la
chouchoute de son papa pour ses deux
fils à la Fabien et Anthony les
relations avec leur père ont souvent été
plus tumultueuses c'est l'enfant à
l'intérieur de lui qu'il l'a pas so
qu'il n'a pas su apaiser et je dis à un
moment c'est vrai que les combats les
plus rudes c'est ceux qu'on mène contre
soi à la mort d'Alain Delon il y aura
pourtant un groupe actuel à se partager
entre les différents héritiers on peut
évaluer raisonnablement le patrimoine
d'Alain Delon à plusieurs millions
d'euros un héritage complexe qui n'est
pas son rappeler celui de Johnny
Hallyday alors Alain Delon comme sa
fille Anouchka exécutrice testamentaire
allons-nous vers une affaire Laetitia
Laura et David
voilà va-t-on vers une nouvelle Laetitia
David Hallyday bonjour maître bonjour à
tous mais sauter chance la semaine
dernière
enfin c'est dû à toute cette équipe
ouais c'est si alors juste une question
parce que on dit souvent on ne peut pas
déshériter ses enfants et moi j'ai des
fiches ici voilà où je vois
effectivement tous les tous les stars
qui ont déshérité leur enfant Alain
Bashung Picasso Elton John alors il y a
une française quand même en Bill Gates
français Bernard Tapie hallucinant il a
pas déshérité ses enfants
absolument pas triste à fond voilà a
déclaré ne pas avoir pu compter sur
l'étage son père créateur des émissions
Robert Laffont et le plus rien en son
décès en fait est-ce qu'on peut déjà en
France choisir 1 de déshériter ses
enfants si on les aime pas et deuxième
question est-ce qu'on peut faire ce
qu'il a fait avoir un test
merci alors première question première
question on peut pas déshériter ses
enfants on l'a vu avec l'affaire Johnny
Hallyday on a bien vu la complications
extrêmes avec on a essayé Johnny a
essayé enfin la veuve de Johnny a essayé
de de passer par la loi américaine pour
ce pour organiser cette succession et
déshériter des enfants ça n'a pas marché
donc en France non mais si on a plus
rien si on fait si on dépense toute sa
vie si on donne tout à sa femme ou si on
choisit un régime de communauté
universelle par exemple qui fait que
c'est l'autre époux qui va absolument
avoir tout il y a un patrimoine unique
oui on peut déshériter on dira pas de
problème
alors Julien Casta vatarien Simon tu as
rien ça c'est fait tu as un scooter une
trottinette
et alors donc on ne peut pas déshériter
par exemple dans le cas de d'Alain Delon
si on en parle il a aujourd'hui trois
enfants ça veut dire que trois quarts de
son patrimoine vont obligatoirement
théoriquement aller aux enfants et un
car il peut en faire ce qu'il veut
d'accord l'offrira il peut vous le
donner à vous
comme la semaine dernière vous racontez
n'importe quoi en fait
je suis désolé
pas du tout en fait ensuite on fait
absolument ce qu'on veut donc là il est
naturalisé suisse depuis 84 donc il
dépend pas du tout de la loi française
en fait je suis d'accord avec vous mais
la loi suisse vous avez exactement
aujourd'hui trois quarts d'exécuteur
d'exécutrice
la loi suisse c'est pas la même que la
loi française la loi suisse n'est pas la
même mais en matière de succession c'est
la même non d'autant que moi j'ai posé
la question en France parce que j'adore
la Suisse monsieur la cible Suisse en ce
moment sur l'émission moi j'ai la raison
c'est vrai que c'est après vous
expliquera un jour ce qui s'est passé
c'est une excellent mauvais divorce il y
a eu quelques parce que dans chaque
émission
je vous le dis la loi française
mais maintenant vous pouvez vérifier tu
sens aimerait ajouter un et je t'en
merde tu vas tu vas me saouler longtemps
pas du tout non mais un avocat reste un
avocat tu vas me faire chier longtemps
non mais Sophie c'est son job quand même
oui mais je sais pas pourquoi enfin
c'est très bien
c'était la deuxième question en fait on
peut choisir un proche généralement on
peut choisir un enfant d'accord c'est ce
qu'a fait Alain pas du tout petit
n'importe quoi
on peut choisir et donc il a choisi sa
fille depuis le début mais est-ce que ça
veut dire que sa fille en revanche
puisqu'ils ont ils ont chacun en gros un
tiers de l'héritage est-ce qu'il peut
choisir qui a il y a ce tiers
obligatoire on va dire pour les enfants
mais que elle est plus donc dans la
partie qui lui reste qui se réservé à
lui il a une petite exactement voilà
elle est parfaitement compris il a une
petite est disponible ça peut rémunérer
d'ailleurs ce travail d'exécuteur
testamentaire exécuteur testamentaire
c'est en fait il va elle va respecter
les volontés de son père d'accord il y a
des choses à donner certaines personnes
cet
héritage de d'Alain Delon alors oui
parce que déjà il y a quelque chose qui
à mon avis peut vous intéresser sur
lequel vous pouvez nous éclairer c'est
qu'il a commencé en fait il a expliqué
qu'il détestait les ventes postes donc
en fait il a commencé à vendre toutes
ses collections d'art de voiture même
dame et cetera et il a accumulé 15 à 20
millions d'euros à peu près rien qu'en
collection et ça c'est ce conseil ce
qu'on sait pas également il a un
patrimoine énorme que ce soit en
immobilier en plein d'autres choses vous
êtes d'accord Sophie
tous les deux d'ailleurs sur le sujet
c'est de faire des donations de son
vivant et c'est vrai qu'en Suisse on est
beaucoup moins taxé par rapport en
France vous êtes d'accord
sur son renseigner sur son héritage
mes parents n'ont pas d'argent donc je
refais des réponses
avec toutes les ventes qu'a fait de long
c'est derrière les années c'est en fait
la guerre entre ses enfants a démarré en
2019 quand il fait un AVC qu'il est
entre la vie et la mort pendant des mois
en fait en train nouschka et les deux
frères Alain Fabien et Anthony tout a
commencé à ce moment-là c'est-à-dire
qu'ils allaient même pas le voir
ensemble à l'hôpital tout est devenu
très très compliqué on lui a expliqué
tout ça après quand il a commencé à
aller un petit peu mieux d'accord là il
a commencé à prendre des dispositions
parce qu'il a bien vu justement qu'entre
ces trois enfants c'était extrêmement
compliqué donc il y a eu Johnny aussi
qui a fait enfin il l'a dit on interview
Johnny évidemment il y a un côté un peu
jurisprudence dans le domaine donc voilà
on a vu sur la fiche derrière parce que
c'était assez mais est-ce qu'on sait le
total est-ce que représente à peu près
c'est impossible mais en tout cas il y a
rien qu'en liquide on parle de 200
millions d'euros 300 millions d'euros
c'est il a tellement je pense que c'est
plus autour de 500 millions d'euros cinq
fois plus et peut-être 5 fois plus il a
pas il a pas beaucoup d'immobilier il a
surtout des œuvres d'arts l'immobilier
il l'a vendu je crois doucher la
collection des bronzes de justement
je sais qu'elle était à Douchy donc chez
Alain Delon il y a toutes les robes
il y a vraiment des pièces d'art c'est
vraiment impressionnant la dit je suis
rentré dans un musée ça fait même peur
il y avait la robe de Romy Schneider
posée sur le lit enfin il y a des pièces
qui sont inestimables est-ce que ça
t'irait pas un bouquin elle capucine
minuit
elle a été chez tu vois
jamais parce que c'est une amie mais le
weekend qu'elle a passé chez les Sarkozy
euh
de toute façon je peux vous dire que
c'est c'est à mourir de rire mais je
respecte faut pas oublier que de long il
est pas juste acteur il est aussi
producteur oui il a été co-producteur de
plein de films comme borsalino etc et
tombe à chaque fois que les fils on en a
beaucoup parlé ici sur la musique etc
voilà donc il touche de l'argent très
régulièrement il a eu des contrats
publicitaires importants qu'il arrive à
la Fabien et entre les deux noms en rond
de l'argent de leur faire ça c'est sûr
et on peut pas déshériter contrairement
aux États-Unis on peut donc absolument
aux États-Unis on peut parfaitement
organiser sa succession et donner à qui
l'on veut
on peut trouver une fondation
qui va prendre soin ou à une personne
qui va prendre en charge
combien l'État prend quand on a 500
millions d'euros combien se sert de
pourcentage sur la fortune c'est 50 % 60
%, ça dépend c'est chaque héritier c'est
chaque héritier qui va devoir payer en
fonction de ce qu'il va percevoir et en
fonction de sa propre fortune mais on
peut dire que ça peut être de l'ordre un
peu plus de 35 à 40 %. alors moi j'avais
moi j'ai lu parce que je veux dire la
vérité je si il me regarde et votre
content parce que mes neveux quand un
peu de sang de moi du coup me dit tout
le temps quand est-ce qu'on va hérité
ouais ça va aller vite
il faut faire du ski à toute allure je
suis derrière plus vite c'est noir vous
êtes sûr et je me suis renseigné comme
j'ai pas d'enfant si bon je voilà disons
ma sœur Perez que c'est par tranche mais
paierai en gros 50% de sur ce que je
vais lui donner et mes neveux
60.000 pour eux 60000 de bœuf 600000
pour mais vous imaginez c'est ça ce que
ça veut dire dans la mesure où vous
n'avez pas d'enfant les seules héritiers
obligatoires ce sont les enfants ça peut
revenir aux parents une certaine manière
mais bon les neveux et nièces il y a pas
d'enfants c'est eux qui vont pouvoir
effectivement
hériter ils sont pas considérés comme
voilà
on peut donner bien sûr
trouver des moyens détournés de ne rien
leur laisser ou de déplacer les choses
c'est donner de votre vivant ce qu'on
appelle vous faire vous pouvez faire des
assurances vie c'est-à-dire que vous
pouvez chaque mois cotiser certaines
sommes dans la dans la du proportion de
ce que vous touchez il faut pas que ce
soit des sommes extraordinaires et là
les assurances vie échappent totalement
à la succession
rapport à Dominique Dominique Tapie qui
fait la une en ce moment qui fait que ça
c'est intéressant est-ce que si moi
demain je suis marié mon mari s'en va il
est mort
mon mari s'en va et toutes ces dettes
derrière moi je n'ai absolument rien
fait je suis dans la société
vous pouvez refuser la succession alors
une histoire aussi de contrat de mariage
non
solidaire des dettes
simplement le contrat de mariage c'est
pas il y a pas le contrat de mariage n'a
rien à voir là-dedans en fait c'est le
vous êtes solidaire des dettes de toute
façon fiscale vous êtes toujours à
partir du moment où vous êtes marié et
que vous soyez sous la séparation ou pas
vous êtes mais là on fait une petite
consultation pour chacun
non en gros pour résumer pour les gens
effectivement voilà quand vous mourrez
ça va aux enfants si ça va pas aux
enfants ça va aux ascendants donc aux
parents sinon au collatéraux sont les
frères et sœurs vous pouvez refuser un
héritage si il y a trop de passifs
l'accepter s'il y a beaucoup de choses
dedans c'est à peu près ça à l'idée
merci beaucoup un petit truc pour
résumer quand même ce que je pense que
c'est quand même le plus important on
parle des enfants moi j'ai côtoyé un
petit peu à la Fabien Delon il y a
quelques années donc l'un des fils de de
long qui m'a expliqué être extrêmement
mal considéré par ses parents et en
particulier par son père sur le plan
financier ne rien recevoir depuis des
années donc ça laisse augurer un peu de
ce qui va se passer et du choix qu'il a
fait de pourquoi il a fait ce choix
c'est quelqu'un qui est qui se sent un
peu le vilain petit canard de la famille
depuis non mais attends quand ton père
est millionnaire voire peut-être même
plus que ça tu peux avoir un petit peu
d'aide de temps en temps obligés de
donner de l'argent
peuvent être amenés à à verser
effectivement une somme vous pouvez
alors c'est triste mais ça risque ça
existe souvent aux États-Unis on peut
assigner ses parents pour toucher une
pension alimentaire si véritablement on
est dans le besoin parce qu'il a fait
c'est ce qui fera probablement
on travaille pas de secret mais avec
Benoît on faisait un moment donné parce
qu'on appelle des booking de boîte de
nuit tu es dans une boîte de nuit tu
dors un peu tu prends de l'argent on en
a fait quelques-uns avec à la Fabien et
je reconnais que ce garçon vraiment dit
pas dans le plus dense voilà on a vu
l'appartement
c'est hyper important
et en plus je pensais que c'était comme
ça mais pas du tout est-ce que théorie
pour dire la vérité parce qu'on est dans
la petite ville que ça dans des dans les
boîtes de nuit il avait un tout petit
studio il avait vraiment pas d'argent il
avait que dalle ce môme et de visage
c'est tellement son père mais vraiment
moi j'avais un choc je disais que le
soleil quoi tu dînes il y en a de long
sauf que il est pas arrivé en Ferrari et
il prend pas du caviar mais qui bouffe
capucine
ce que tu dis Florian faut pas oublier
que c'est la version de Alain Fabien
parce que c'est vrai que de l'eau c'est
un mal dominant c'est quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup souffert aussi il y a des
problèmes avec ses fils pas du tout du
coup pas avec la fille et à la Fabien
n'est pas assez pas le le monstre et les
enfants non
de long et les enfants ont que souffert
c'est compliqué que ça c'est de l'eau
c'est pas le montre là aussi quand je
commence par dire je serais rien mais
c'est pas plus de ma gueule il y avait
une campagne qui devait être faite sur
Eau Sauvage cette campagne magnifique où
il y a le père et cette campagne est
proposé au fils le fils était évidemment
très heureux de refaire cette pub
magnifique et l'éthique et le fils a le
père a pris son téléphone et lui cette
phrase exacte chez les deux noms il y a
qu'une seule star et tu arrêtes ce
contrat sinon c'est moi qui l'arrête